he is getting set for his first full
year at the starting controls of the
Baltimore Ravens offense that appears to
be revolutionized to make sure that they
get the most out of this young man he is
Lamar Jackson how are you Lamar I am
doing better for talking to you
let's let's start with with the the way
it appears that your head coach started
the training camp season by talking
about revolutionising the offense with
you at the tip of that spear Lamar what
What did he say you know basically just
saying you know this master changer you
know our error arm you know those guys
but then we know those guys who had
theirs you know nice errors performed at
a high level you know wanna super balls
and stuff like that and you know is you
know me just being able to do multiple
things out down the field you know what
this running a pass and there's gonna be
definitely different on for this team
you know it's a different team and you
know we just got aspects master this is
the LJ era essentially do you think do
you think he was borrowing from your
your Twitter handle
Lamar you should definitely ask him look
different from last year from when we
saw you seven starts in them one playoff
start Lamar oh my mind a lot clearer out
there you know I'm just being in a
system or a whole year um you know we're
not this system we got a whole new
system going on but just been in you
know from the start
and you know right now you know it's
definitely different from spring we just
my next seven each and every day we're
just a farm and getting better each and
every day
and it's looking good well I mean so
what what can you reveal then of how the
offensive system is different from what
we saw last year I just hope our you
know our speed is a lot differently a
lot of speed around us this year I got
our chemistry to be a lot stronger
you know um because I came in the middle
of the season military end of the season
didn't have chemistry with my guys you
know I was with the second team you know
performing and practices and got through
in week 11 or whatever it was and we was
off you know
some games we offer complete some passes
but not all the ones I still complete
and you know this this camp has been
going very well even see my you know
performances a lot better than it was
last year spring well count is looking
better so what about it's interesting
you mentioned throwing because Lamar I
mean it's it's kind of ridiculous you've
heard it since I'm sure Louisville and
now here you are in the pros saying your
your run first and that the passing game
is gonna be substandard because it's not
sustainable in the NFL what do you say
to that or whatever you're gonna say you
know we have to do our thing go out
there and we're gonna out the song
that's all okay you know I can't change
keeping my discount season I here yet
you know people wanna say whatever they
gonna say and I just gotta perform
Lamar Jackson Ravens quarterback here on
the Rich Eisen show your coach John
Harbaugh was on NFL Network earlier this
week I don't know if you heard this but
it was mentioned him that Cam Newton who
is a big man and maybe weighs a touch
more than you Lamar is his career most
he's ever run in a season was 2017 a
hundred thirty nine times and the coach
said for you to take the over is that is
that accurate way more than running suit
so I mean can you sustain an entire
season or again you I said the numbers
earlier on and you ran in 147 times last
year but just in your seven starts 119
rushes I mean the over is going to be
way past it can you can you sustain that
physical aspect in the NFL Lamar
absolutely no I put on weight but I
don't think I'll be running you know as
much as I did last know there was a lot
of RP owes a lot of Sun changes and
lashes games and stuff like that so this
is gonna be totally different
how does Hollywood Brown looking I don't
think he's been out there yet but when
you talk about speed
you know four three four two and I'm
really definitely fast so long I guess
I mean I'm gonna keep circling around on
this cuz we're talking about
revolutionising the the offense and and
clearly you have the pieces to do it
how's it going to look I mean how how
will this how will this operate in an
NFL Lamar you know I can't start can you
talk about you know each and every day
we look better and better what we doing
you know whether it is our peels or run
the ball in our back or as gamers are
looking incredible right now but you
don't have to see when the game when the
game time you know practice is gonna be
practice you know games gonna be games
just so so ever so ah okay
where are all the Heisman trophies on
the team have you guys have brought your
trophies in you know you've got how many
there's three right there's three Rd
okay have you brought them all together
at some point
no I know we haven't we haven't thought
about it or spoke about it you know we
just you know they say you know Heisman
I won't even break it up break it up
where is your husband right now where
does that got mine at home at home
do we know where Ingram's and RG threes
are they've got to be at home I mean
come on Lamar you got to get them all
together you know what you should do
here's due tomorrow okay here's what you
and I think Mashhadi has the cash to do
this you should get a table right that
you can hook up to electrodes and it
shakes and you put your Heisman trophies
on the table like an electric football
game and you let it go Medical yes and
see and see who scores first from your
Huysmans have you seen Bashar ease boat
Lamar we can handle this it's it's I
think I might have understated by using
the word boat yeah your predecessor once
once once told him to put a bag of money
on the table and he did so you're set up
Lamar to see you are set up to see this
what has Mark Ingram brought to this
team an offense Lamar Jackson leadership
you know his poison you
you can just tell his experience you
know he's always you know pompville
practices too like it's a game you know
or maybe if you don't know something
know he asked me know cuz there's a new
system to all of us and you know it's my
job to be able to let him know he has
and stuff like that
he's a great Batman got speed power
listing with him you know for going
again and I I left off another Heisman
Trophy that you're gonna see twice a
year and you already saw last year and
Baker Mayfield what was that what was
that game like for you last year was a
fun game you know ya was able to perform
at home
my first game playing against those guys
it was a great game going back before mm
sofa win us it was incredible I'm I'm
just looking forward to it I'm meeting
every year yeah I know twice a year too
so uh let me just run through it one
more time with you here Lamar I mean
everybody's talking about the Browns cuz
Odell's there now and Baker Mayfield's
there and his first his first full year
as a as a starting quarterback I mean
that the conversation about them making
the playoffs for the first time and
forever to use a frozen phrase that is
that is being discussed the Steelers are
the Steelers so there's always the towel
wavers out there and your team that's
one at all not many people are talking
about you have going back-to-back
Lamar are you talking about that in your
locker room at all yeah we don't you
know we don't talk you know we just come
from we just performed you know we want
to win games
we're not the team's gonna be on social
media talking about what we should be
doing this doing that we just go out
there have fun we just come up with w's
we don't do too much talking I don't
really care about what people say at all
but you're ready to go for it go go go
oh my gosh you must be so excited what
does it mean to be a full-time starter
from the get-go oh nice you know relax
you know you really are a anything this
is going out of just winning and that's
what it's all about you know winning
games at NSF yeah and and in terms of
that I mean just the confidence that the
team has clearly put in you do the fact
that the offense is revolutionized and
the reason why they did it is because
you're the guy what does that mean for
you my team believe in me knows
the vomit on the behind me want to
present you know I just gotta do it I'm
always know I do be Lamar these hey
Lamar I appreciate the time I really do
you know so let's let's stay in touch
throughout the season I would definitely
like that and you know if there is some
way you know after one of your
touchdowns that you could signal to me
and the listeners of this show is there
is do you have a celebration all planned
out I really don't to get about to the
reference anything okay how about you
you what you slip the ball to the ref
with your left hand with your left hand
that's your way of saying to the Rich
Eisen show and the host by the way that
has already come out and said that the
Ravens this is the division for the only
the Ravens to lose that I truly believe
in your t know if you've heard that yeah
okay so in just as a tip of the the cap
of the of the helmet if you will your
left hand when you score touchdowns you
said give the ball to the ref with your
left hand and I know that's for me
you've revolutionized that all right
Lamar let's chat soon okay you got it
that's mr. Lamar that's Lamar Jackson
Ravens quarterback right here in the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app